all right some scary video coming up for
you Yellowstone Park officials are
reminding visitors that the wildlife in
the park is wild and to give them space
after a nine-year-old girl was hurt by a
bison shocking video captured the moment
here's a look there is good news
unbelievable the nine-year-old is okay
she received medical attention and was
released the park says the incident is
being investigated and get this there
was a witness who told CBS this morning
that people were petting this bison and
all the reports are there were a group
of about 50 that were very close by they
stay stay Stevan d five feet away they
are wild animals but they seem so big
and so slow and so graceful majestic
comes to mind you don't think they're
gonna start running oh and by the way
the people running to the right out of
frame their parents heron know been
reported that that was apparent I'm
thinking would you run if your child was
there I don't think so no come on you
don't know what you're gonna do but the
good news is that the little girl is
okay yeah that is right but the park
rangers are really really irritated
because they say stop petting these
people and this happened at Yellowstone
last year also leave them listen to the
Park Rangers all right